what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back again with another installment
of our beyond omega level series where
we break down the most powerful
characters in all of comics
and today we're going to discuss one of
the most powerful villains that have
been introduced in marvel comics in the
last decade
and one that will actually be introduced
in the mcu in the next thor movie
gore the god butcher so gore was created
by jason aaron and esau ribbik and first
appeared in
thor god of thunder number two in 2013
and gore
would go on to antagonize thor
throughout a story arc that's widely
considered to be one of the best stories
ever written which really begs the
question
how is it that jason aaron became such a
great writer i know exactly how he did
it he used
skillshare brand deal time you guys know
what time it is
so skillshare is an online learning
community with thousands of inspiring
classes for creative and curious people
where you can explore new skills develop
existing interests and get lost in
creativity you know one of the questions
i get all the time
is how i grow my youtube channel like
how do you grow on youtube how do you go
from being a person with no subscribers
to a ton of subscribers well there is
a video on there by mkbhd who's probably
the top tech youtuber with
a ridiculous amount of subs that
actually walks you through the entire
process how to craft your videos how to
script them the whole nine yards which
in a lot of ways
has been exceedingly helpful for me even
as an established creator there's also a
whole bunch of videos about marketing
and different things along those lines
but that's of particular interest
if you guys are looking to grow a
youtube channel and become a full-time
youtube content creator that's one that
i would highly suggest you guys check
out so to get you guys started the first
1 000 of you guys of my subscribers who
click the link in the description will
get a one month free trial of skillshare
so you can start exploring your
creativity today and after that it's
only around 10
a month so make sure you guys click the
link make sure you guys go check out
mkbhd's video on how to be successful on
youtube and let's get back into our
content
so gore was an alien living on a
desolate planet and his life had always
been pretty miserable his mom
died defending him from wild animals he
grows up he gets married and has a
family but then his wife and his kids
all
die and all the while gore and his
people are praying to the gods and even
sacrificing members of their tribes to
appease the gods but nothing ever gets
better so
gore decides that the gods must not be
real which leads to him being exiled
from the rest of his people now sometime
after this
gore happens across two gods that have
fallen to his planet apparently after a
grueling battle one of which of course
is null the symbiote god now only one of
them is still alive
and he asks war for help gorby comes and
raised at the audacity of this god
asking for help when he and his family
were suffering and the gods did nothing
to help
meanwhile the sword of no bonds with
gore and then gore uses it to kill the
other god now in reality gore had only
believed the god to be dead but it would
later be revealed there was actually no
now if you're not familiar with null he
definitely gets his own beyond omega
level video sometime probably in the
near future but basically
he's the god of the symbiotes so the
racist symbiotes that venom carnage and
all the rest belong to
noel created them and this sword that
was bonded to gore is actually the
all-black necro sword the very first
symbiote that null had ever created
now once he's bonded with all black and
used it to kill a god gore develops an
insatiable desire to kill as many gods
as he can which leads to him adopting
the moniker
of the god butcher now while gore has no
superhuman abilities at all before
encountering all black he becomes
extremely powerful once he bonds with
the necro sword for example
as soon as he kills his first god gore
uses all black to create a suit of armor
that allows him to fly off into space
and enables him to survive in the vacuum
of space now one of the primary
abilities that all black grants gore is
that he can form weapons with the
symbiote
including swords that are strong enough
to badly injure thor he also uses the
symbiote to form a variety of constructs
much of the same way that we've seen
other marvel symbiotes change shape into
a variety of weapons so
gore makes his symbiote constructs into
a mace or chains or whatever he wants
but one thing that makes gore's
constructs especially devastating
is that if they manage to get inside the
body of one of their victims
they can eat away at them from the
inside and eventually kill him now gore
can also use his mastery over darkness
to create constructs called black
berserkers that are basically creatures
made out of darkness that are extremely
powerful in their own right for instance
one black berserker was able to fight
thor evenly for hours so this is one
construct representing only a fragment
standing up against thor who himself is
a beyond omega level character so this
is an extremely
impressive thief but not even the most
impressive thing we see the black
berserkers do when battling king thor
a version of thor from the future that
ascended to the throne of asgard
an army of gore's berserkers drown king
thor in darkness for a period of 900
years
and this is after they've already killed
everybody else in asgard now all black
also affords gore superhuman physical
attributes as well
gore is extremely durable having
survived multiple blows from mjolnir
as well as a god blast from king thor
that sent him crashing into a planet at
the speed of light furthermore
he appeared to be at least equal to thor
in terms of strength and he was able to
hurl
chunks of a moon at two different
versions of thor from the surface of the
planet he created
a feat which needs some explanation and
that explanation will give us even more
of an idea how ridiculously powerful
gore is so the first
is that three different versions of thor
came together one from the past before
he was worthy to left mjolnir the most
frequently seen version of thor that
lifts milner and
king thor from the future who we
discussed earlier and the reason for
this is simple
all three versions of thor were getting
their butts kicked
when they tried to battle gore one on
one because gore was doing his god
butchering over several thousand years
so that's why there's multiple versions
of thor here but on to the second part
of this feat which is the fact that gore
created an entire planet out of
all black so that's basically just a
planet-sized version of the sword he's
been manipulating
just on a much larger scale and it's on
this planet that gore manages to
imprison and enslave
a countless number of gods to do his
bidding most notably constructing his
ultimate creation a weapon that will
bring about the destruction of
every deity in the universe the god bomb
so the god bomb is such a formidable
weapon that thor
is unable to destroy it with the chunk
of a stark but before gore is able to
activate it he's confronted by
all three versions of thor now drawing
upon the strength of the gods being
killed by his black berserkers gore is
able to not only defeat
all three versions of thor but nearly
kills all three of them which
also just lets us know that we're
dealing with a force to be reckoned with
in gore this is one of the other crazy
things about his character too
gore literally tortured the god of
torture to death
it was nuts but gore's plan is
eventually thwarted by his son who you
might remember died thousands of years
ago and that's one of the big reasons
gore became who he is in the first place
when he gets his powers gore creates a
whole new family out of his constructs
but when one of his son sees him kill
the other and then learns he also killed
her mother he realizes that gore is the
bad guy
and begins praying to thor now not only
does gore's son start praying to thor
but
all the gods gore hasn't killed yet do
too so thor gets a
massive power boost which allows him to
tank the godbomb explosion
and rip all black from gore rendering
him powerless and unable to stop
thor from cutting his head off it's
literally one of the coolest moments man
thor's wielding two mjolnirs and the all
black
it's ridiculously cool but since this is
basically a video not only about gore
but on all black as well i think it's
worth pointing out that thor's exposure
to all black was so physically taxing on
him that he died
sure i mean he rose three days later
just like jesus but all black was so
powerful that thor
couldn't handle being exposed to it
which is kind of weird since gore was
able to stay bonded to it for thousands
of years thor couldn't withstand being
bonded to it for a short time but
whoever said anything in comics needed
to make sense now eventually
gore would return when loki acquired all
black and unwittingly resurrected gore
in the process now of course
gore goes on to defeat both loki and
thor who was at this point the all
father of asgard and then fashions the
all black in the annihilation blade a
weapon capable of destroying planets but
even more impressively even after being
killed once again
gore is able to merge his essence with
the universe effectively becoming his
own universe that he dubs the all-black
necroverse of course
this doesn't last because thor defeats
him and eventually purges the universe
of gore's influence because that's just
how things work the good guys win
in the end but still the fact that gore
was able to become
a universe definitely earns him a spot
on the list of characters that are well
beyond omega level with that being said
guys we're gonna bring this to an end
thank you all for watching and i will
catch you all later
peace